I want to do like just one bit of
follow-up on this entire Jared schmeck
let's go Brandon thing that took place
uh because even the last bits of the
story that were still standing are now
falling apart so I
on the one hand who cares about this guy
but the fact that he is being made a
hero much like Kyle Rittenhouse is now
being made a hero by the right really
tells us a lot about where the right is
now given who they are lionizing and
also martyring that's another aspect of
this so here's the story
this guy Jared schmeck over the holiday
weekend was able to get on the phone
with Joe and Jill Biden and during that
phone call he dropped in the phrase
let's go Brandon let's go Brandon is a
euphemism or a code for f Joe Biden so
he told the president to go f himself
here's a reminder of that clip
[Laughter]
I hope you have a
yeah yeah I hope you guys have a
wonderful Christmas as well uh thank you
let's go Brandon let's go Brandon I'll
agree hey by the way where are you in
Oregon
where's your home
I think we lost him yeah okay so after
this took place this guy Jared schmack
started getting criticized significantly
by some although people like Don Jr
praised him but there were people
criticizing Jared schmeck because it's
quite disrespectful if your view is
respect the Office of the President you
don't call up the president and say F
you go f yourself the equivalent of that
and Jared schmeck started to uh say that
he's a victim everybody he was just
expressing his first amendment rights
and people are curtailing those by
criticizing him and it's like no
consequences to your speech are also
protected by the very same Free Speech
right that we all share
um and he also said something
interesting which is I'm not a Trumper
I respect Joe Biden I'm not a Trumper I
just have concerns cut to Yesterday When
Jared schmeck appeared with former Trump
advisor and Breitbart propagandist Steve
Bannon wearing a red Mega hat saying the
election was 100 stolen and he wants us
to believe he's not a Trumper he's just
a guy expressing his concerns it's just
a pathetic joke take a look at the video
let's listen to the audio
I know it was said in a in a joking
manner in a humorous manner but it's a
very serious uh thing and I mean it's it
was one way for me to like man I got a
chance right now to to voice my
disapproval of of this man and his
administration
your John Q public what is that what is
that disapproval can you define that for
us
yeah yeah by the way the idea that we
would particularly like it's great to
hear from just random people that's
great we want to know we want to take
the Pulse of what's going on and hear
from people
but Steve bannon's interest in hearing
from this guy who we only know about
because he told the Pres president to go
f himself like who in particular cares
what this guy has to say let's go
Brandon is and I've said it in other
articles I am a Christian man uh it's
for me it's God first and foremost I
don't follow any one man blindly
um some of the Medias run with that and
said I don't support Donald Trump that's
absolutely false and remember he said
I'm not a Trumper Trump is my president
and it should still be president right
now the election was 100 stolen
um so I just want to make that clear
um but uh let's go Brandon is is more
than just F Joe Biden yeah let's go
Brandon is it encompasses the the
entirety of our frustration with
Joe Biden the administration the leftist
mob the council culture the mainstream
media they're the ones who made this a
thing and uh we're we're F Joe Biden is
about the cancel culture
what is this guy talking about well as
conservatives we're able to find humor
in this um but there's terrible things
going on uh we've got the debacle in
Afghanistan I mean they're not even
talking about it it's a verbal ink plot
of just unhinged disjointed talking
points but he's not a Trumper oh and
also he's wearing a red Maga hat anymore
it's crazy to me how quickly they they
forgot that story and no one's talking
about it there's still people trapped
over there
um we've got the supply chain issues
we've got the inflation rates we've got
uh terrible policies on on abortion I'm
a very pro-life person
um and uh absolutely terrible what's
funny about just as like a I mean this
it's hard to find a more ignorant person
who thinks they are really informed the
abortion line just to pick one thing
right the abortion line is particularly
wacky because Joe Biden's been president
11 months almost almost a year right
well actually 11 three weeks short of a
Year Joe Biden has been president
there has been no loosening of abortion
policy since Joe Biden took over from
Donald Trump and in fact with the Texas
abortion law if anything it is harder
today to get an abortion overall in the
United States than it was 11 months ago
when Joe Biden became president so when
you actually look at what these folks
are saying and this there's lots of
people who don't even pay attention to
politics they just I don't care about
politics you ask them who's the vice
president they might not even know like
people who are just completely tuned out
this guy is an example of someone who
believes they are knowledgeable about
what's going on
and people like this vote and he has no
idea whatsoever and at the end of the
day he basically told the president of
the United States F you to his face and
now he's calling himself the victim so
let's let's make this the final point on
the Jared schmeck Story he's no one any
of us should care about uh in terms of
his opinion and he despite being a
Christian and being from the side that
says we've got to have the right you
know tone and respect for all of these
different institutions he is now being
criticized because he told the president
to go f himself that's that's the end of
the story and we'll have these clips on
our Instagram if you are listening today
and want to watch them find us there uh
at davidpackman show on Instagram
one of our sponsors is self-decode
self-decode is a genetic testing and
Analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your DNA this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about what
of substantive value can we get from
these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific DNA as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a DNA kit to get my saliva I did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks I had my results I found for
example that genetically I'm not big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma unfortunately
I'm at slightly increased risk of
headaches which is true which is true
and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation
Etc very very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to ten years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code Pacman